good morning John it's Hank
on Tuesday coming to you from Melbourne
Australia that is just behind this
window here getting real close to the
lamp job Friday actually it's not very
pleasant sensation on my fingers you
don't want to do this thing where they'd
have like the Google autocomplete
vlogmas pioneered that that was our
thing and then everybody's stole it but
anyway I'm not bitter creativity is
shared everyone builds on what everyone
else has done before we couldn't copy
the work other people I couldn't say
words I'm gonna modify my own idea I'm
gonna go to twitter.com and type why is
Australia I spelled it super wrong why
is Australia performing what the hell
I'm not good at geography but since when
is Australia in Europe at this I believe
this tweet is about your a vision look
what is Europe anyway it's an idea why
is Australia why is Australia the best
forsake rock you know what be Radley
what the Frick is psych Rock we're gonna
find out together sign crime
why is Australia so far away so
continents interestingly are less dense
rock that is floating essentially on top
of the sort of jelly-like interior of
the earth and how those giant rocks
float around on the jelly ball of Earth
is a fairly random process but like
something that we've modelled pretty
extensively I'm not a geologist but
geologists do exist and you should ask
one of them
Gaby wants to know why Australia is so
slow with moving releases like I need to
watch hustlers are in or else I won't be
a valid game I've also heard the Huskers
is good and it is we're Ludacris that we
live in this global world and we still
do content releases by continent
twitter.com is right here everybody
knows about the thing you can't do this
to us anymore
Sigrid wants to know why Australia is so
obsessed with fairies they got fairy
floss that's cotton candy fairy bread
which is the thing bread with sprinkles
on it fairy penguins which is a kind of
penguin fairy lights I don't know what
that is the fairies which I'm going to
assume our boats that you take two from
one place to another oh my god it's not
a boat this is way better than fake rock
the magical mystery tree it says right
here in the YouTube description the
fairies is an international and unique
concept so it's both international and
unique but it's proven itself as one of
the top TV series touring publishing DVD
music and licensing properties in
Australia well if I'm here to watch
fairies on YouTube as a child this is
the marketing language I'm looking for
all right I'm gonna mix it up because
you know what most people are just mad
about Australian politics in this search
so I'm just gonna search why is Hank
green
why is that green so oh gosh I've take
it back all right well I think this
counts as video I'm gonna go watch the
fairies on YouTube and then maybe go
edit my book on the banks of the Yarra
River like a lucky little turd John I'll
see you on Tuesday